[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde
États-Unis Chine et Europe vers une
écologie de guerre
la décarbonation de l'économie est au
cœur des échanges commerciaux mondiaux
et des relations internationales c'est à
juste titre que l'on parle d'écologie de
guerre au regard de la compétition
effrénée que ce livre les États-Unis et
la Chine dans le domaine de l'industrie
et des technologies vertes qu'on en juge
le président Joe Biden a injecté sous
l'appellation civiline dira ou une
flèche de réduction actes l'octroi de
369 milliards de dollars pour booster
l'économie et l'industrie américaine
décarbonée à la vérité du dumping
écologique pour relocaliser sur place
les industries liées aux énergies
propres et à l'automobile la Chine n'est
pas en reste pour la domination mondiale
en matière de transition écologique avec
des performances exceptionnelles sinon
dominatrice sur le marché des énergies
renouvelables notamment les panneaux
solaires des terres et métaux rares et
dans la fabrication des batteries au
lithium composant essentiels de la
voiture électrique et l'Europe me
direz-vous et bien elle possède aussi
son sigle le nzia ou net 0 industrie
actes vous voyez c'est aussi en anglais
des investissements importants pour
renforcer l'éventail de ces technologies
vertes mais elle est toujours à la
recherche d'une unité d'action parce
qu'elle fait face à des dissensions
essentiellement franco-allemande et cela
hypothèque l'efficacité d'un éventuel
Fonds européen de souveraineté
écologique qui tarde à se concrétiser
nous allons chercher à comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants les
aboutissements pardon de cette écologie
de conquête à base de rivalité
commerciale et nous allons le faire avec
mes invités que je vous présente Anne
lovergeon vous êtes dirigeante
d'entreprise je rappelle que vous avez
dirigé l'entreprise Areva aujourd'hui
Orano et que vous dirigez vous êtes
président de ALP Boris Ravignon vous
êtes maire de Charleville-Mézières et
président par intérim de la dame Olivier
luizzi associé
PwC stratégie Christian Saint-Étienne
vous êtes économiste et professeur
émérite au CNAM
[Musique]
vous avez vu cette citation de Thierry
Breton commissaire européen fini la
naïveté maintenant c'est l'action alors
nous allons en parler en faisant d'abord
aborder cette bataille commerciale et
écologique en termes stratégique nous
aborderons dans un second plan la
rivalité Chine États-Unis et pour
conclure l'Europe et notamment la
position de la France est-ce que vous
considérez que la décarbonation de
l'économie constitue aujourd'hui une
urgence stratégique au sein du concert
des nations
je crois que de fait c'est effectivement
une préoccupation mondiale elle est
alimentée par les inquiétudes des
citoyens par exemple on a longtemps dit
que la machine européenne était beaucoup
trop
lointaine pas assez proche des
différents citoyens des pays donc je
pense que effectivement la préoccupation
sur le changement climatique est une
préoccupation tout à fait prioritaire
mais c'est pas la seule et le danger
c'est effectivement de n'avoir plus de
politique que de politique sur le
changement climatique et c'est parfois
l'impression qu'on peut en avoir moi ce
qui me fera beaucoup mais je pense qu'on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir c'est autant
la Chine ou les États-Unis ont
effectivement pris conscience après
beaucoup de refus et de négation de
l'importance du changement climatique
mais ils en font effectivement une une
arme pratique pour
à la fois supporter leurs entreprises
pour pouvoir les propulser mieux alors
que nous au niveau européen on a
tendance effectivement à en faire
quelque chose qui est une sorte de de
punition parfois un peu collective de
d'interdiction de mise en place de
mécanismes très compliqués le la taxe
carbone on va rentrer de système très
très très très lourd alors même que les
deux autres côtés Chine et États-Unis
ils ont tendance à développer des
politiques qui sont en faveur de leurs
entreprises au premier chef donc je
dirais que la façon d'interpréter la
priorité climatique est très différente
dans les trois ensembles que l'on voit
alors on va rentrer dans le détail vous
allez voir
tous les aspects mais ce qu'on constate
aussi c'est que le multilatéralisme qui
a été quand même une grande tendance
depuis les années 60 jusqu'aux années
2000 avec la création de l'OMC avec
l'idée qu'effectivement on trouverait
des politiques communes on voit
aujourd'hui un retour effectivement aux
politiques de blocs et où effectivement
quelle est ta puissance de feu pour que
tes idées passent et c'est vrai que
cette tendance est très profonde et on
voit que l'OMC après l'échec du cycle de
Doha se retrouve un peu le bec dans
l'eau sur à peu près tous les sujets
alors vous êtes d'accord sur cette
approche là Boris Ravignon une petite
nuance peut-être je crois quand même que
on a l'habitude de européenne ce
flageller là sur ce sujet là ceux qui
sont cohérents ceux qui sont rationnels
avec l'objectif quand même d'arriver à
décarboner l'ensemble de nos activités
pour éviter le drame climatique parce
que quand même comment savoir nous donne
un avant-goût de ce que le monde
pourrait devenir si nous n'avons pas des
politiques climatiques sérieuses les
seuls qui est aujourd'hui des politiques
climatiques sérieuses c'est recaler avec
des trajectoires calés sur l'objectif de
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050
c'est l'Europe c'est les seuls les
autres effectivement
comprennent comprennent que le monde
évolue dans ce sens là et il voit des
opportunités ce que nous n'arrivons
encore pas complètement à faire je crois
que on est il faut quand même là sur le
sur le fait qu'on est nous avec l'accord
de Paris une stratégie cohérente pour
des carbonner l'économie X qui est
indispensable à survie de l'espèce
humaine sur la planète je crois qu'il
faut pas s'enflamme j'ai par contre je
partage tout à fait le fait que
aujourd'hui nous n'avons nous ne sommes
pas encore du tout organisés pour en
faire une formidable opportunité de
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
de l'Europe de développement d'une la
maîtrise de technologie que nous avons
par ailleurs écoutez c'est juste un
premier constat que je vous demandais
est-ce que christian Saint-Etienne
Olivier luizy vous considérez que c'est
une priorité j'imagine que oui mais je
vais vous laisser répondre et sur ce que
la distinction faite par un overgent
c'est plus abstrait de de l'autre côté
c'est plus commercial ailleurs qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez mais on rentrera dans
le détail si vous voulez juste là une
première approche non mais je suis
obligé d'être d'accord avec Anne sur le
fait que
la stratégie européenne écologique qui
est souhaitable mais elle est punitive
d'abord et très réglementaire et qu'elle
ne promeut pas les entreprises
européennes et surtout elle est elle
oublie les ce qui se passe au niveau
mondial si on regarde
à l'horizon 2025 la Chine représentera
35% des émissions de CO2 en 2025 et
l'Europe 7% et quand on regarde les
débats en Europe on a l'impression que
c'est l'Europe qui fait 70% des
émissions de de gaz à effet de serre
rappelez quand même qu'il y a un
milliard 400 millions d'habitants en
Chine et qu'en Europe on est autour de
450 millions mais on est d'accord mais
ceci étant si on considère la terre
comme un écosystème intégré il faut
regarder les sources quelle que soit le
nombre d'habitants et l'Europe est un
acteur on a l'impression que c'est le
principal émetteur il faut juste
rappeler les chiffres la Chine toute
seule c'est cette fois à l'horizon de 2
ou 3 ans 7 fois les émissions de CO2 de
l'Europe l'un de suite à l'horizon 2030
l'Asie c'est les deux tiers des
émissions de CO2 au plan mondial donc je
trouve que le niveau européen on est
trop dans le punitif l'autopunitif et
pas assez dans la promotion des acteurs
stratégiques européens votre avis il y a
pas que sur l'écologie même sur le
numérique et surtout les sujets Olivier
luorsi sur cette distinction là qui est
faite aujourd'hui bon est-ce que c'est
un sujet central oui et comme Monsieur
Ravignon vient de le dire on commence à
en sentir je dirais pas simplement les
mesures par des scientifiques mais aussi
des épisodes climatiques aigus qui qui
nous impactent et qui vont nous impacter
de plus en plus donc le raid des
éléments climatique et la question du
carbone est critique si on va sur le
champ de l'environnement et j'irai pas
très loin c'est pas il y a peut-être
d'autres personnes autour de la table
qui sont en plus mais encore une fois il
n'y a pas que le dérèglement climatique
il y a des problèmes d'eau il y a des
problèmes de sol qui est là sont un peu
écrasés par le sujet des carbonations ça
veut pas dire qu'il est pas important
mais qu'il y a d'autres sujets et puis
si on en vient sur le plan économique et
qui va réussir à faire cette bataille
c'est-à-dire qui va réussir à mettre sur
le marché les équipements qui sont
nécessaires à trouver l'appart
technologique des solutions il y aura
aussi une part comportementale de notre
façon de consommer il y aura les deux on
est effectivement dans une guerre c'est
pas la seule on l'a aussi sur les puces
électroniques on l'a sur les produits
pharmaceutiques on l'a sur la gestion de
la donnée etc etc et dans cette bataille
là malgré l'affirmation qui était votre
point d'introduction du commissaire
européen la naïveté ne semble pas être
avoir complètement disparu et on reste
quand on fait la liste de ces sujets là
qui sont des sujets de souveraineté
environnementales je pharmaceutique de
données on reste quand même sur une
approche qui reste très je dirais modéré
en termes de volontarisme au niveau
européen mais on pourra y revenir avec
des chiffres vous êtes dirigeants un des
dirigeants de PwC et à ce titre vous
connaissez bien l'industrie alors la
question qui se pose c'est que l'année
enregistré un record des émissions
mondiales de carbone mais en même temps
une accélération des consommations
d'énergie et notamment de l'électricité
peut-être que les deux choses sont liées
mais en même temps on observe des
investissements très importants dans les
technologies et l'industrie verte que
faut-il envisager de plus aujourd'hui
pour enrayer la hausse de la température
et faire diminuer ses émissions de
carbone alors je c'est une politique
globale moi je suis sur l'industrie
justement c'est 20% des émissions déjà
donc il faut pas oublier qu'à 80%
la part elle est en plus je vais
déborder sur l'autre l'industrie
aujourd'hui on a une approche je vais
prendre par exemple l'approche française
il y a de l'argent qui existe qui a été
mis sur la table c'est considérable
j'étais encore dans un conférence
téléphonique avec des investisseurs dans
le domaine de la pharmacie ils veulent
décarboner leur processus on a fait la
comparaison des quelques pays européens
et des dispositifs nous avons avec la
partie décarbonation de France 2030 au
moins sur le papier le dispositif le
plus puissant pour accompagner les
entreprises à la décarbonation en termes
de chiffres ça c'est indéniable ensuite
c'est un processus qui va surtout
s'appliquer au processus industriel
c'est à dire la partie du carbone qui
est émis pendant la fabrication
si vous me demandez qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire de plus pour l'industrie
je pense qu'il faudrait élargir ce champ
là et la première chose c'est
accompagner les industriels à la
conception l'éco-conception de produits
qui sont certes économes pendant leur
fabrication en énergie et en émission de
carbone mais qui le sont aussi pendant
leur usage et également pendant leur fin
de vie tout ce volet déco conception des
produits on est dans un monde qui change
il y a pas que le carbone il y a plein
de choses qui changent autour de nous
les rapports de force géopolitiques vont
nous amener à réinventer tous nos objets
du quotidien la voiture est un exemple
avec la voiture électrique on en
reparlera certainement mais c'est pas le
seul et là aujourd'hui dans notre façon
de voir les choses on n'est pas encore
remonté à la source c'est à dire comment
on réinvente les produits pour le monde
de demain qui nous permet d'avoir moins
de carbone pendant leurs production leur
utilisation leur fin de vie mais
également qui utilisent des matériaux
qui nous rendent moins dépendants qui
utilisent des compétences qui sont
disponibles en France en étant
compétitive etc etc cet exercice de
réflexion profond sur la conception de
produits n'est pas lancé alors Boris
Ravignon quid de l'industrie ou
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ailleurs pour
faire baisser
un exercice de prospective à l'ADEME qui
s'appelle transition 2050 on a regardé
on regarde plusieurs scénarios pour
atteindre justement la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050
les éléments de base de ces différents
scénarios c'est d'abord partout où on le
peut de baisser nos consommations
d'énergie donc il y a
qui est lui aussi parlé tout à l'heure
de d'une dimension comportementale tout
ce qu'on appelle la sobriété toute cette
interrogation qu'on a sur est-ce que
j'ai besoin de d'utiliser ma voiture
pour faire 300 mètres aller chercher le
pain est-ce que ce que j'ai besoin
d'avoir un grand appartement tout ce qui
touche au comportement effectivement une
part importante qui permet de faire
baisser la consommation par la sobriété
on a ensuite des technologies qui
améliorent l'efficacité on fait le même
service mais par contre on utilise moins
d'énergie et puis il reste toute une
partie de l'énergie qu'il faut là
effectivement décarboner et pour
l'essentiel le travail qu'on a à faire
c'est de développer des énergies qui
vont produire une électricité
renouvelable alors ça va être ça peut
être du nucléaire ça peut être dans le
cas des différents scénarios aussi un
développement assez considérable des
énergies renouvelables et éoliennes
solaires et différentes variétés
d'éoliens la géothermie etc et donc en
fait en même temps c'est pour ça que on
va vivre dans les années qui viennent à
la fois normalement si on tient bien nos
objectifs une baisse de consommation on
a déjà un petit peu commencé la sobriété
énergétique cet hiver par exemple et
puis en même temps une augmentation de
la consommation et de la donc
nécessairement de la production
d'électricité la part de l'électricité
dans notre consommation d'énergie va
avoir tendance à augmenter parce que
c'est l'électricité qui décarbonne en
grande partie alors Christian
Saint-Étienne je vous place d'emblée une
casquette d'économistes
et donc vous avez rappelé que ce que
fait l'Europe les États-Unis ou la Chine
c'est pas la même chose mais dans ces
émissions de carbone qui qui grimpent
quelle est la part relative de
responsabilité si vous voulez dans cette
élévation de température
le logement et le transport sont des
éléments clés de la carbonation mais
un Africain
est-ce que dalle si je puis dire dans
cette ça change très rapidement bon l'un
de qui est pas l'Afrique
si c'est la première population mondiale
va doubler elle
a déjà massivement augmentée elle va
vers 2 milliards d'habitants c'est le
les deux secteurs de l'économie mondiale
sur le plan démographique où on a une
croissance forte c'est l'Afrique noire
donc du côté de l'Afrique et les pays
musulmans d'Asie avec des taux de
fécondité des femmes en Afghanistan et
au Pakistan qui sont supérieurs à 5
encore donc c'est dans ces pays-là qu'on
a une progression très importante de la
population mais la Chine ne s'est pas
engagée à baisser ses émissions mais
abaisser la production de démission de
CO2 par unité d'augmentation de PIB donc
parce que c'est un peu l'efficacité
énergétique mais elle s'est pas engagée
à baisser la quantité de CO2 qu'elle
aimait alors sur la question centrale
si on veut vraiment aller vers une
croissance économique des carbonée il
faut électrifier le système électrifié
le système ça suppose de doubler la
production électrique ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est qu'il y a pas de projets
actuellement de doublement de la
production électrique le l'énergie
nucléaire ne fera pas le job on va en
parler très largeur mais en termes
globaux si on veut doubler la production
électrique sur un peu plus de 20 ans les
premières centrales nucléaires sont
opérationnelles dans 15 ans elle si on
doit passer de 100 à 200 en termes de
production électrique les centrales
nucléaires vont peut-être amener 15 à 20
on va rentrer dans le détail et donc la
question centrale c'est est-ce que on
est sérieux parce que si on veut
éliminer le charbon et le pétrole
il y a pas il y a pas de vie économique
sociale et politique sans énergie alors
écoutez à nos vergence je voudrais qu'on
avance un petit peu dans ce sujet la
pandémie de covid tout comme la guerre
en Ukraine ont montré la dépendance
extérieure notamment de notre pays mais
de tous les pays pour la production de
biens de technologie de ressources
indispensables à la consommation
on a vu les troubles économiques et
sociaux que ça génère est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à un protectionnisme
économique et écologique autrement dit
la barrière carbone
pour faire quelque chose parce qu'on
peut pas rester
là quoi la compétition est faussée en
quelque sorte si on se protège pas alors
c'est vrai que on est aujourd'hui dans
une ambiance générale car activé le
covid parce que ça a été le révélateur
pour beaucoup de pays de la dépendance
sur les produits pharmaceutiques ils
sont beaucoup d'autres de la Chine donc
il y a une sorte de de on a longtemps
été plus des consommateurs que des
citoyens finalement surtout ces sujets
et on s'est réveillé avec
deux choses qui paraissaient qui sont
parfois un peu antagonistes d'une part
la nécessité effectivement de décarboner
d'être beaucoup plus attentif à
l'environnement et puis de l'autre une
autre notion que beaucoup avaient oublié
c'est la sécurité sécurité énergétique
sécurité alimentaire tout ce qui
paraissait sécurité Pharm tout ce qui
paraissait absolument évident c'est de
toute façon quelque part ça
l'électricité ça sort du mur enfin il y
a aucun problème on sait réveiller un
petit peu avec ben oui cette dimension
là elle existe aussi et là on en revient
un petit peu à la naïveté européenne qui
considérait que finalement on avait qu'à
acheter sur étagère quelque part et on
trouverait tout ce qu'on veut je pense
qu'on se réveille dans un monde beaucoup
plus complexe ou effectivement sécurité
et environnement sont deux choses qui
vont pas forcément de paires ensemble et
les deux on va devoir les mener parce
que rappelez-vous cet hiver quand les
Français ont entendu parler et les
Allemands et le reste de l'Europe de
coupure d'électricité or cette constater
qu'effectivement nous allons depuis
bonne quinzaine d'années vers toujours
plus d'électricité et comme le disait
Christian c'est la façon des carboner si
effectivement on produit cette
électricité de manière propre c'est la
façon des carbonées d'économie mais
c'est électricité comment la produire
alors si vous suivez la Commission
européenne on va rentrer on est 42,5% de
renouvelables
42,5 % de ça on sait pas
bon on a perdu énormément de temps en
querelle théologie en France idéologique
et en Europe alors lutte anti-nucléaire
les gens qui étaient entières novelables
tout ça est complètement dépassé et ce
qui m'inquiète moi personnellement c'est
qu'on continue à par exemple la décision
qui a été prise à l'unanimité des États
membres qu'en 2035 on aurait plus de
moteur thermique donc on aurait plus que
des moteurs électriques
désolé de le dire il n'y a pas eu de
vraies études pour savoir si on avait
les capacités électriques alors la
capacité électrique on pourrait les
avoir et on n'a pas la puissance
électrique derrière alors c'est un petit
peu c'est de la physique un peu avancée
mais si vous voulez charger votre
voiture suffisamment rapidement il faut
effectivement gagner de la puissance
nous n'avons pas la puissance électrique
d'ici 2035 disponible pour remplacer
l'ensemble des moteurs thermiques donc
c'est bien beau d'avoir des idées
généreuses et dire formidable on renonce
cette horrible butter thermique qui au
passage quand même a permis beaucoup de
choses et le remplaçait par des moteurs
électriques alors qu'on en a pas les
moyens physiques je voudrais vous donner
l'explication
précisée pour les téléspectateurs cette
chose là
la Chine envisage
de développer une très grosse
usine de batterie en Europe
on sait bien qu'elle domine déjà dans le
domaine des batteries est-ce que ça le
même effet si elle nous exporte ses
batteries qui sont indispensables pour
le véhicule électrique ou si elle les
fabrique chez nous
est-ce que autrement dit est-ce qu'il y
a pas une politique protectionniste à
avoir à l'égard de la Chine dans un
domaine aussi stratégique parce que
c'est un vrai on est tous favorable à la
décarbonation on sait que l'électrique
va se développer et là
on se retrouve devant quasiment un fait
commercial accompli alors je dirais que
les méga usine de batterie on en voit
une quantité incroyable toute ne vont
pas se réaliser et elle se réaliseront
d'ailleurs dans les pays où
l'électricité est la moins chère
l'électricité est la moins chère ou
aujourd'hui c'est en Norvège dans le
nord de la Suède c'était en France
ça n'allait plus donc ça c'est un vrai
sujet de préoccupation et puis ces
usines c'est méga usines batteries il va
falloir les remplir avec un certain
nombre de matières premières de matières
premières transformées et ça le pipe
amont on l'a pas donc ça c'est aussi un
sujet les matières premières l'Europe il
y a pas de politique européenne sur les
matières premières alors que la Chine
est obsédée par le sujet alors la méga
usine de batterie chinoise elle est très
intelligente ils ont raison de la
promouvoir pourquoi il faut la faire en
Europe aussi parce que ça permettrait
s'il y avait un jour une législation
européenne comme il est en train de se
mettre en place aux États-Unis si
effectivement on dit il faut que les
batteries soient fabriquées en Europe
pour que il y ait des subventions
comme on a dépendait comme on a Hyundai
Hyundai avait zéro usine aux États-Unis
il y a le l'Iran qui se met en place
il faut fabriquer aux États-Unis pour
que le consommateur l'acheteur et 7500
dollars et puis des avantages fiscaux
des carottes qui sont mises en place etc
Hyundai viennent décider d'investir 11
milliards de dollars aux États-Unis ils
avaient pas d'usine ils en font une aux
États-Unis pour faire des voitures aux
États-Unis donc les chinois ils sont pas
du tout idiots ils se disent
stratégiquement c'est du jeu de Go les
Européens ils vont mettre le temps mais
peut-être qu'ils vont se dire
qu'effectivement il faut mettre des
carottes en place pour pousser les leurs
industries nationales qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on met une usine de batterie
chinoise et comme ça on pourra vendre
des voitures chinoises même si il y a
des embargots
vous avez posé la question de la
dépendance ou de l'indépendance alors le
première chose c'est que on peut lister
toute une série de sujets stratégiques
et ils sont déjà apparus un petit peu
autour de la table il y a les
équipements pour la transition
écologique pour les nouveaux mobs de
mobilité pour la pharmacie on peut
parler des puces électroniques du
stockage de données
même si le monde va vers des tensions
géopolitiques beaucoup plus renforcées
qu'avant il est illusoire de croire
qu'on sera totalement indépendant même à
l'échelle européenne la véritable
bataille qui n'est pas fait c'est de
choisir nos dépendances et de choisir
nos points forts aujourd'hui la Chine
transforme plus de 80% de tous les
métaux stratégiques fournis plus de 80%
des batteries et avec l'Inde fournissent
plus de 80% des molécules actives pour
notre pharmacie les États-Unis ont 80%
de la propriété sur le design des puces
contrôle tout ce qui est de la donnée et
du stockage c'est deux ensemble là sont
capables de créer une interdépendance
qui leur permettra peut-être d'aller
trop loin dans cet exéquilibre là
l'Europe n'a rien où on pourrait dire
80% de cet objet là ce service la
stratégique et détenu par l'Europe fut
un temps le nucléaire était une
spécialité européenne française on va
l'aborder aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
on a perdu de la distance on a perdu de
l'innovation
quels sont les interdépendances que l'on
veut créer parce qu'encore une fois une
indépendance pure n'existe pas illusoire
alors non on parle même pas d'autonomie
ou d'autarsie qu'on peut même si de
temps en temps quand même et puis alors
sur le protectionnisme moi je pose une
question simple quand nous
subventionnons avec le bonus automobile
bonus voiturette électrique des voitures
qui sont d'origine de partout et qu'on
voit débarquer des voitures d'origine
chinoise que les États-Unis ont décidé
de le de limiter ce type de bonus à des
voitures produites aux États-Unis avec
des critères un peu stricts je pense que
nos concitoyens ne vont pas tarder à
réagir et nos politiques derrière et
donc je pense qu'effectivement on va
avoir une tendance à une certaine forme
de protectionnisme qui va falloir
assumer mais encore une fois dans quelle
stratégie avec quels objectifs quelles
sont les technologies que nous voulons
maîtriser quelles sont les dépendances
que nous sommes obligés d'accepter
on se prépare dans les années qui
viennent à investir massivement vraiment
dans tous les équipements de la
transition énergétique le Commission
européenne dit sur les technologies de
la transition énergétique c'est autour
de 600 milliards d'euros par an donc
c'est assez considérable alors chiffre
de Laia
l'énergie sont encore plus importante ce
qui prennent d'autres choses mais rien
que sur les technologies 600 milliards
dans le monde et ça et bien il est
crucial absolument vital pour l'Europe
que l'essentiel de ces investissements
là soit aussi des investissements qui
l'aident à conforter effectivement sa
souveraineté je suis d'accord on
pourrait discuter très longtemps de
souveraineté d'ailleurs pourrait noter
que des cartes données complètement
notre industrie c'est sortir tous les
fossiles de notre balance commerciale ça
va nous faire ça va nous rendre mettre
dans une situation souveraineté
énergétique quasi totale alors ils ont
2050 il y a plus de gaz fossiles et plus
des le plus de pétrole et donc on est
quasiment à 100% de souveraineté
énergétique sauf qu'il faut pas qu'on
troque une souveraineté contre une autre
ou plutôt une dépendance contre une
autre et là la dépendance et en fait et
les technologies c'est vraiment le sujet
c'est de savoir d'où viendront les
panneaux solaires qu'on convainc à
installer dans les années qui viennent
aujourd'hui 90% viennent effectivement
de Chine 90% le marché des cellules
photovoltaïques c'est la Chine et c'est
pas arrivé tout seul c'est pour ça que
le commissaire breton sur le la naïveté
je crois pas qu'on en soit guéri et
surtout elle dure depuis longtemps parce
qu'il y a eu une industrie notamment en
Allemagne du panneau solaire extrêmement
importantes elle a été tuée assassinée
par les Chinois qui avec un dumping
effréné faisait que les panneaux qui
arrivaient en Europe les laisser venir
bien sûr que non et bien sûr que non
c'est pour ça que moi à mon sens c'est
pour ça qu'à mon sens il y a deux
évolutions au niveau européen qui sont
indispensables l'une sur les aides
d'État il faut qu'on puisse
effectivement aider davantage nos
industriels et puis une autre sur la
protection aux frontières qui
aujourd'hui est embryonnaire alors
Christian Saint-Étienne une question un
peu idéologique d'un côté il y a des
économies libérales de l'autre côté des
économies j'allais dire il libérale en
tout cas autoritaire est-ce que le jeu
n'est pas faussé de la concurrence
finale c'est sûr que le jeu est faussé
alors quand la Chine est entrée à l'OMC
en 2001 un des américains s'y était
opposé pendant les 15 années précédentes
ils ont
était berné par la réponse chinoise au
11 septembre ils ont cru que les Chinois
les accompagner la politique américaine
de lutte contre certains nombre d'États
considérés comme terroristes par les
Américains mais la raison pour laquelle
les Américains s'opposaient c'est que il
y avait deux volets de l'OMC avec des
protocoles que les chinois ne voulaient
pas signer d'abord l'ouverture des
marchés publics alors il a fallu
attendre yunker il y a 5 ans ou quatre
ans pour qu'ils disent tiens c'est quand
même gênant que
90% des marchés publics européens sont
ouverts chinois alors que 2% des marchés
chinois sont ouverts aux Européens bon
ben là il y a des règles qu'il faut
mettre en place il y a beaucoup de
spécialistes sur ces questions qui
disent il faut avoir une politique
commerciale ouverte certes mais basée
sur la réciprocité c'est à dire si le
marché chinois de la commande publique
est fermée il faut fermer le marché des
du public européenne on sait pourquoi ça
ne s'est pas fait c'est parce que le
leadership je sais pas si on va
l'aborder mais le leadership politique
en Europe a basculé en faveur de
l'Allemagne il y a une dizaine d'années
notre désindustrialisation et la France
a beaucoup de défauts mais pendant la
longue période où elle a été très
influente en Europe elle a largement
mené une politique européenne pour
l'Europe l'Allemagne mène une politique
allemande aujourd'hui en Europe
extrêmement mercantiliste donc les
Allemands ont accepté lara-kiri de leur
industrie de panneaux photovoltaïques
parce que en contrepartie il vendait
beaucoup de voitures et de machines
outils en Chine maintenant il voit que
les Chinois vont les supplanter sur
l'automobile et que ils sont devenus
très bons à machinoutis donc il se peut
que les Allemands bougent mais avec 20
ans de retard et donc effectivement ça
n'a pas de sens enfin moi je me bats
exactement comme Boris sur le fait que
faire du de la production d'électricité
avec des panneaux photovoltaïques
importés de Chine c'est complètement con
donc il y a un moment il faut avoir un
minimum de cohérence sur le plan
stratégique et ce qui est encore plus
irritant c'est que je termine par là le
CEA développé des technologies de
panneaux photovoltaïques c'est nel qui
construit une usine géante de panneaux
photovoltaïques sur la base de la
technologie du CE en Sicile qu'est-ce
qu'on fout donc pourquoi il y a pas une
politique stratégique française sur ces
sujets là
[Musique]
alors là vous venez de voir citation de
Geoffroy route des yeux patron du Medef
mais aujourd'hui
un mandat renouvelé nous n'avons pas le
choix l'Europe doit s'aligner sur le
niveau des subventions américaines alors
les États-Unis disposent on l'a dit de
près de 400 milliards de dollars avec
les rats l'Europe dit avec son sigle
nzda net0 industriac
qu'elle va mettre beaucoup d'argent on
parle d'un fonde souveraineté on est
très loin très loin d'une parité en
termes d'investissement
vous en pensez Olivier lui aussi alors
il y a plusieurs éléments d'abord il y a
des chiffres qui se qui se confrontent
l'Europe d'ici moi j'ai 400 milliards à
mettre sur la table c'est sans doute
vrai mais c'est plutôt en amont du cycle
sur l'innovation et sur la recherche ce
n'est pas pour aider la production or
d'une des spécificités de l'infection
réduction Act c'est bien pour cibler la
production elle-même et des
capacités
comparables c'est la première chose et
finalement l'Europe dans dans sa grande
générosité d'aide n'aide pas la
production directement la production
industrielle elle le renvoie aux États
avec des mécanismes soit direct d'être
d'État soit un peu plus complexe qu'on
appelle des pieds qui permettent d'aller
plus loin donc en fait la réponse pour
Adira aujourd'hui l'Europe dit à peu
près donc j'ai pas mon fond qui est
prévu pour l'été mais les choses qui
commencent à glisser on sait pas quand
elles s'arrête dit c'est aux états de le
faire
si on prend l'Iran américain et qu'on le
ramène à la taille française
il faudrait mettre sur la table 39
milliards d'euros c'est une simple règle
de 39 milliards d'euros pour aider nos
industries à développer des capacités
alors dans ces cas la réponse est ah on
a déjà France 2030 oui mais dans France
2030 il y a seulement 17 milliards
d'euros pour aider l'industrie les
autres c'est pour aider la recherche
donc 17 milliards versus 39 et sur ces
17 milliards il y en a que la moitié ce
qui est déjà énorme et encore une fois
je l'ai dit au départ on est extrêmement
bien noté sur le sujet pour les sujets
de décarbonation et si je rajoute encore
une couche je dirais ça passe par des
concours des appels à projets ce ne sont
pas des aides automatiques et ce que les
industriels apprécient énormément avec
Lyra américain c'est que c'est un
guichet vous déposez vous avez le papier
d'engagement c'est un calcul automatique
beaucoup de souviens pas et beaucoup de
crédits d'impôts et donc globalement si
on met tout ça bout à bout on voit que
il y a quelque chose d'extrêmement
disproportionné aujourd'hui entre ce qui
est proposé par les États-Unis et ce qui
est actuellement en place en Europe et
notamment en France mais alors pourquoi
on n'a pas autant de moyens que les
Américains puisque Olivier lui Enzy
vient de nous montrer que ce que met
l'Europe c'est des budgets qui sont
biaisés puisqu'ils concernent à la fois
la recherche développement la production
pourquoi il y a ce manque c'est
difficile j'ai pas la réponse
universelle sur le sujet mais je dirais
que l'approche de l'Europe est
essentiellement une approche
réglementaire une approche limitative ce
qui vient d'être voté c'est
effectivement un nouveau marché carbone
un système effectivement très complexe
qui va se mettre en place à partir 2025
2026 pour que tous les produits importés
en Europe venant de manière
extra-européenne on puisse compter le
carbone qui a été utilisé pour le
produit et que en rentrant en Europe ces
produits qui peuvent être très
composites très complexes puissent être
effectivement
avoir une taxe donc notre approche est à
la fois réglementaire et taxatrice
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
l'approche américaine elle je dirais
notre approche elle est un peu bâton
l'approche américaine et les carottes
alors elle est carotte pour le
consommateur si vous prenez un bon
produit américain avec les bonnes
caractéristiques la voiture électrique
avec la batterie et le système de
vitesse américain PAF 7500 dollars donc
ça c'est très concret pour le
consommateur
il y a absolument pas d'origine donc le
consommateur américain il faut il est
poussé acheté américain et les
entreprises qui effectivement
aujourd'hui s'installe ou sont déjà
installés aux États-Unis ont des crédits
d'impôts donc c'est une politique
carotte donc ça s'appelle pas la
préférence nationale ça on peut la plaie
comme on le veut
national ça a une connotation
particulière ça a fonctionné dans le
monde domaine agricole pendant
seuls les voitures produites en Europe à
60 % seront éligibles au prime pour
acquérir une voiture électrique mais
pourquoi on le fait pas c'est juste pas
c'est l'idéologie qui a dominer l'Europe
c'était c'est peut-être même pas contre
le droit européen mais par pratique on
pourrait le faire parce que c'est des
aides aux consommateurs donc on peut le
regarder c'est une préférence
communautaire mais comme le disait
Christian tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
la politique allemande qui est devenue
très forte d'ailleurs on a une
présidente de la Commission européenne
allemande
la politique allemande vis-à-vis de la
Chine a toujours été de faire très
attention à la Chine puisque c'était une
sortie c'était une voie de sortie très
importante pour leur voiture pour
l'industrie automobile qui compte
beaucoup mais aussi pour des tas de PME
PMI donc la priorité c'était pas embêter
les Chinois donc quand les Chinois
effectivement mouvement sont arrivés
alors aujourd'hui
ressuscité une industrie photovoltaïque
en Europe c'est vraiment très difficile
ça prend du temps et ça demanderait un
effort que le sale prenez par exemple ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
de la dynamique aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant dans l'éolien nous avons des
constructeurs éoliens européens qui vont
pas très bien c'est paradoxal ils ont
des carnet de commandes significatives
mais la hausse des taux d'intérêt les
problématiques de de ça devient de plus
en plus compliqué de les installer
ils ont dû se restructurer je consolider
vous avez aujourd'hui un peu un Maras
mais d'ailleurs quand vous regardez les
chiffres on était à 41 milliards
d'investissements dans l'éolien en
Europe en 2021 on est à 17 en 2022 vous
voyez il y a une chute très
significative
jusqu'à présent les joueurs européens
étaient les plus importants avec qui aux
États-Unis et bien aujourd'hui celui qui
fait égal égal avec Vestas ces Goldwing
en Chine c'est un chinois qui commence à
exporter deux plus en plus et les
industriels de l'éolien aujourd'hui
disent attention en Europe attention il
va nous arriver ce qui est arrivé au
photovoltaïques jusqu'à présent réaction
rien donc la vitesse aussi de nos
actions ou nos réactions est un énorme
problème parce que quand vous partez sur
du dumping sauvage la mort de alors moi
je dis la mort quand on dit 90% de
photovoltaïques en Europe européen non
c'est beaucoup beaucoup chinois c'est
beaucoup plus il y a quelques Européens
qui font du montage des Chinois et qui
comptent pour européens mais la vérité
98% de chinois il ne risque de nous
arriver la même chose dans le faut dans
le dans l'éolien et on ne et notre
Commission européenne dit toujours la
quelque chose qui dit c'est
42,5% de rénovelables en 2030 c'est tout
Oui Boris
mais praticien de l'économie je vois
bien ce qui se passe aujourd'hui par
exemple dans le grand test on avait sur
le site où cette implanté Smart puis
Smart est parti la possibilité de faire
venir un producteur indien alors
semble-t-il avec d'autres capitaux mais
ça plaît rexolar pour un planter une
très grande usine de production de
panneaux photovoltaïques mais il a fini
par renoncer à son projet pour pour une
raison toute simple c'est qu'il suffit
pas d'avoir simplement des aides pour
avoir une politique industrielle et
avoir des industries qui se développent
il faut aussi que le marché sur lequel
on s'implante quand on y est installé on
bénéficie d'une certaine protection
Eric sola a dit écoutez moi vous êtes
l'Union européenne un marché ouvert
tellement au 80 à toutes les
importations venant de n'importe où dans
le monde que je n'ai aucun intérêt à
venir me localiser ici je serais très
bien à continuer à produire mes panneaux
solaires en Inde et à vous les envoyer
puisque de toute façon vous n'avez
aucune politique commerciale aux
frontières et surtout pas de
protectionnisme donc je crois que si on
veut à la fois avoir un développement
industriel dans toute cette technologie
qui sont aussi importantes il y a
nécessairement à aider un certain nombre
d'industrie à se développer mais a aussi
assuré une protection minimale du marché
avec un ajustement aux frontières et
celui qui est qui a été voté c'est un
certain premier pas faut jamais
m'ex estimer la difficulté qui a
progressé dans le cadre européen mais on
est sur des produits bruts on est sur de
l'aluminium du ciment des aciers et tout
ça c'est pas monter en charge de manière
très très progressive c'est pas du tout
à la hauteur des enjeux alors écoutez
dans le concert des nations tout le
monde sait que les nations sont égoïstes
et que chacun cherche à défendre son
intérêt national mais à votre avis
christian Saint-Etienne est-ce que
l'Union européenne est très butèrent
bien souvent des choix de l'Allemagne
qui dictent le tempo économique et
écologique et c'est ça qui accroît la
vulnérabilité de l'Europe dans ce
domaine par rapport à la Chine et aux
États-Unis essayer de répondre
directement ce que le téléspectateur se
pose la question je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité allemande considérable
pour les raisons que j'évoquais une
politique mercantiliste qui favorise
uniquement les entreprises allemandes et
je pense qu'il y a une responsabilité
française c'est pas les Allemands qui
nous ont conduit au cours des 15
dernières années à oublier la politique
stratégique énergétique qu'on avait mené
dans les 40 années qui précèdent si on
avait mené une politique cohérente on
serait pas à genoux aujourd'hui c'est la
même chose dans d'autres domaines je
prends la production de de
microprocesseurs
l'Europe produisait 20% des
microprocesseurs dans le monde il y a 40
ans et on est tombé à 9% et on veut
revenir à 20 sachant encore plus on va
produire des microprocesseurs de moyenne
qualité
en termes de
finesse du de la gravure des
microprocesseurs on va pas produire les
microprocesseurs dernières génération
sur ces sujets là les Allemands qui ont
beaucoup voté comme nous sont lancés 4
usines un géant de fabrication de
microprocesseurs nous nous sommes sur un
projet d'une demi-usine sur Grenoble
avec une opposition écologiste locale
d'un considérable qui retarde les
investissements sur l'intelligence
artificielle on vient d'avoir les
chiffres en 2022 les Américains c'est
plus de 40 milliards les Chinois c'est
13 milliards les Allemands sont à deux
et demi et la France a un ennemi on voit
que sur tous les sujets stratégiques on
investit pas
à la hauteur des enjeux mais je reviens
sur sur la question qu'on évoquait les
panneaux photovoltaïques ou les ou les
voitures électriques
il y a rien qui nous interdit dans le
droit européen ni à l'OMC de faire
exactement comme les américains c'est de
dire de dire les aides aux consommateurs
sont donnés en contrepartie d'une
production au moins 60% sur le
territoire européen donc si on le fait
pas c'est parce que on n'a pas de vision
de souveraineté européenne réelle et
d'ailleurs les questions de souveraineté
les premières mesures significatives ont
été prises au printemps 2022 après 40
ans de débats pendant lesquels on n'a
rien fait donc alors que les Américains
et les Chinois mènent des politiques de
souveraineté comme les Indiens comme les
Russes comme les Brésiliens donc la
question c'est qu'est-ce qui fait
basculer l'Europe vers une politique de
souveraineté pas pas de fermeture un
dernier point sur ce sujet les la
question de la souveraineté elle était
étudiée et conduite en termes de
politique aux États-Unis depuis plus de
60 ans
tous les présidents américains on ne
sait pas mais quand ils arrivent au
pouvoir ils produisent un document de
stratégie et ça fait une quarantaine
d'années que les Américains ont dit que
la souveraineté c'est pas la fermeture
et c'est pas l'autarcie c'est d'être
autonome sur 6 sujets clés
qui sont basiques pour être souverain il
faut pouvoir nourrir son peuple donc
l'agroalimentaire doit provenir de son
territoire il faut pouvoir soigner son
peuple donc la pharmacie est clé nous
avions la première industrie
pharmaceutique d'Europe on l'a tué on
est tombé au quatrième ou cinquième rang
on est en dessous de l'Italie parce que
toute la politique de santé française
depuis une trentaine d'années c'est de
taxer les les médicaments de telle sorte
que les industries pharmaceutiques sont
allés produire donc il faut nourrir son
peuple il faut le soigner il faut une
politique sur la défense il faut une
politique sur l'énergie on avait une
très belle politique de l'énergie
pendant 50 ans on est tombé et il faut
une autonomie sur le numérique on voit
pas de politique intégrée au plan
européen sur toutes ces filières alors
il y a des petits débuts de choses
depuis 18 mois mais après 40 ans on a
rien fait alors écoutez on écoutant
christian Saint-Etienne ils viennent
nous dire que tout ne vient pas tous nos
mots ne viennent pas de l'Allemagne mais
il y a un sujet qui fait dissension
entre la France et l'Allemagne c'est le
nucléaire et notamment
l'impossibilité de déployer des
investissements verts sur l'hydrogène
qui viendrait du nucléaire
est-ce que vous pensez à votre avis que
devant cette difficulté
il faudrait élargir le tandem
franco-allemand à l'Italie ne pas rester
j'allais dire à coquiner si je puis dire
à cette relation
privilégiée puisqu'elle elle nous
empêche en quelque sorte la
réindustrialisation
non enfin je pense que moi je pense
comme Christian c'est à dire il faut pas
expliquer
tous nos problèmes par les autres
une grosse partie de nos problèmes
viennent de nous-mêmes
voici ma toujours tout à fait étonné
c'est de voir à quel point quand on
prend les dirigeants chinois les
dirigeants américains l'obsession qu'ils
peuvent avoir de deux grands sujets
l'énergie et les matières premières
c'est à dire que vous regardez à nouveau
président chinois fait une tournée il va
faire la tournée de tous les producteurs
de pétrole de la base en Afrique par
exemple donc ils sont sur l'énergie des
matières premières c'est des sujets
absolument primordiaux pour eux or force
est de constater que nous avons eu des
politiques historiques en France là
dessus qui était très forte sur le
nucléaire sur l'énergie en général voilà
le fait d'être indépendant au maximum
même s'il y avait une dépendance au
pétrole bien évidemment et beaucoup
aussi au gaz il y avait l'idée
effectivement de construire une
indépendance nationale et cette
indépendance nationale s'était pas
seulement en termes de moyens de
production mais c'était l'industrie
derrière qui était capable de fournir
matière première pareil bergm inventaire
général ouverture de mine bon tout ça
terminé on est rentré dans une idée moi
de ça fait 20-25 ans que je constate
qu'effectivement pour l'énergie oui
c'est facile tout le monde peut en faire
sort du mur ça sort du mur les matières
premières on sait toujours pas réveillé
les matières premières ça va être un axe
essentiel on le voit parce que tout le
monde parle de batterie mais c'est très
bien les batteries électriques mais
c'est plein de matières premières qui
sont effectivement non seulement détenus
beaucoup par la Chine en Chine mais vous
regardez toute l'Afrique il y a des
mines un peu partout de ces métaux rares
détenus par des chinois ou avec lequel
les avec lesquels la Chine a des
intérêts commerciaux donc nous sommes
dans ces domaines alors on a dit il faut
faire des renouvelables tout à fait pour
ça vraiment je me suis beaucoup battu
pour développer des renouvelables dans
Areva
d'ailleurs j'ai deux ministre des
Finances successives qui m'ont dit que
je les décevais beaucoup franchement
c'est pas sérieux les moulins à vent
enfin vous croyez pas que les moulins
avant un avenir donc ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on a développé
des politiques et on ne sait pas
préoccuper de l'industrialisation qui
avait derrière et ça c'est extrêmement
choquant c'est à dire que il y a une
sorte de dichotomie de dire bah oui on
va prôner des des nouveaux équipements
mais on se préoccupe absolument pas de
savoir qui va les produire donc je crois
que la France et ça et là alors c'est
vrai que l'Allemagne dans sa politique
antinucléaire a été comme on dirait je
l'inspiration de beaucoup
d'intellectuels en France
de beaucoup de journalistes et c'était
une idée reçue que le nucléaire c'était
finalement complètement ringard et que
l'avenir était renouvelable bon
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que le
nucléaire est bien utile et un vrai
avenir c'est pas la solution j'ai
toujours dit le nucléaire c'est pas la
solution mais il y a pas de solution
sans nucléaire donc c'est une partie de
la solution mais on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement on a réussi en disant à
casser le jouet mais à cassé le jouet de
manière presque
systématique alors il y a une commission
d'enquête parlementaire qui a été
excellent conduite qui a entendu
beaucoup de gens pour moi mais qui a
conclu que ces 25 ans d'erreurs
politiques et ces 25 ans d'erreurs
politiques ont été vraiment mais
absolument dramatique alors arriva par
exemple couper en deux Areva
aller donner la construction de
réacteurs à EDF qui a bien des
difficultés qui en a pas vendu un seul
enlever les moyens de fonctionnement
alors que tout le reste des pays
aidaient leur des westing house alors
prenez wasting out c'est très
intéressant c'est dirigé par des
Français aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
tous les gens du système énergétique
français n'avait plus de boulot sont
partis aux États-Unis bossaient donc il
faut quelque part qu'on retrouve le sens
faut arrêter d'accuser les autres il
faut se dire que nous-mêmes il faut
qu'on retrouve le sens des réalités et
sortir des idéologies il y en a assez
alors vous présidez l'ADEME a toujours
été anti-nucléaire c'est insupportable
oui écoutez elle est peut-être pas
aujourd'hui mais je voulais écouter on
va terminer puisque il nous reste très
peu de temps
le débat est venu sur la
réindustrialisation
sans réindustrialisation pas de salut
Olivier vanzi la réponse est non que
l'industrie qu'est-ce que ça apporte on
vient d'en parler longtemps ça apporte
de la souveraineté
vous avez cité un certain nombre de
champs si derrière vous avez pas une
industrie agroalimentaire une industrie
de l'énergie etc etc de la pharmacie
vous n'avez pas de souveraineté ça
apporte quelque chose qu'on sous-estime
ça apporte de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement je le dis souvent
quand il manque de l'amoxine dans les
pharmacies on met un antibiotique de
base qui existe ça va pas mettre la
France à genoux mais
non pas forcément mais vous allez
soigner moins bien vos enfants et en
tous les cas vous instilez un doute de
la part de la population sur la capacité
de votre outil économique à délivrer des
biens de base et ce doute là à mon avis
il a un effet politique citoyen qui est
beaucoup plus puissant on a parlé
d'environnement il y aura la partie des
comportements que nous devrons changer
il y a la partie des solutions
technologiques sans industrie nous ne
déploierons pas les solutions
technologiques à la bonne échelle et
puis le dernier point qui est pour moi
le premier c'est la cohésion
territoriale l'OCDE a sorti un chiffre
qui peut être un peu contesté mais la
France est le premier pays sur la
décennie 2006-2016 d'ailleurs avant les
crises à concentrer la création de
richesse dans ces métropoles 80% de
notre création de richesse aurait été
fait dans les métropoles les deux pays
européens suivants sont un peu
particuliers c'est le Danemark et
l'Irlande parce que c'est des pays mono
métropoles donc un effet capital celui
qui vient après à moins de 60 %, c'est
le Royaume-Uni qui nous ressemble un
petit peu donc on a une politique
service de poste industriel des
industrialisations et de concentration
de la richesse dans le métropole
appartient là il faut pas s'étonner
d'avoir des mouvements dans les
territoires et l'industrie permet de
remettre des emplois qualifiés des
carrières faire le lien avec la
transition digitale et environnementale
dans les têtes voilà alors Boris
Ravignon là dessus
Olivier lui aussi l'industrie c'est
extrêmement important chez un territoire
où on aime toujours l'industrie et il y
en a encore heureusement beaucoup dans
notre pays où on a il y a une vraie
culture une vraie passion pour pour
l'industrie comment comment on fait pour
que cette transition énergétique qu'on
va réaliser qu'on doit réaliser pour les
raisons climatiques qu'on a je crois
tous indiqué profite effectivement à nos
territoires c'est vraiment ça le sujet
on a dit il y a des conditions au niveau
européen le fait d'avoir par exemple à
carte qui permet de conduire d'une
politique industrielle au niveau
européen et et de protéger le marché
européen et puis et ensuite et il faut
pas il faut pas l'oublier et
l'aubergement vient de démontrer en
creux sur le l'industrie nucléaire ou
finalement quand il faut une politique
de filière il faut qu'on arrive à
renouer avec des politiques et des
stratégies de filière avec de la
cohérence et d'agir dans le temps il y a
encore notamment plein de sujets qui ne
sont pas réglés parce que 2050 c'est
proche mais en même temps c'est Corre
relativement loin il y a des sujets qui
sont pas réglés la capture est le
stockage de carbone par exemple ça c'est
des sujets qui technologiquement
aujourd'hui ne sont pas réglées il faut
qu'on mette le paquet pour être capable
peut-être de profiter de cette option là
sur l'hydrogène je crois là encore
aujourd'hui que il y a plein de choses
qui ne sont pas arrêtées et que c'est
précisément en investissant maintenant
qu'on a une petite chance de peser sur
les choix qui qui seront faits ça va
être la même chose sur les bien on
parlait de l'éolien terrestre mais
l'éolien marin et notamment l'éolien
flottant et bien voilà une filière dans
lequel la France a aujourd'hui des
positions assez intéressantes poussons
là pour que demain on Méditerranée ou il
y a un pas de plateau continental on
puisse malgré tout développer des
éoliennes flottantes enfin il y a encore
plein de d'options
annexes mais comme vous êtes un élu de
l'Est les petites questions qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait au niveau de la
reconversion de Fessenheim qui était une
centrale nucléaire qui a été arrêtée
de juste je crois que les collectivités
locales se ont été réunis dans un
certain créer un certain nombre d'outils
on a défini des espaces sur lesquels qui
étaient premiers à leur
industrialisation et puis il y a eu
beaucoup de contraintes réglementaires
qui sont abattus et donc là on avait des
dizaines d'hectares à réutiliser
finalement et on se retrouve avec
beaucoup moins donc je crois qu'il y a
il y a un vrai sujet on rejoint si on
aime l'industrie si on veut qu'elle se
redéploie il faut aussi qu'elle trouve
des espaces pour le faire et la
reconversion des friches alors quelqu'un
qui vient de l'est où on en a beaucoup
et bien c'est un boulevard pour
redéployer nos industries merci Boris
Ravignon écoutez voilà le temps écoulé
est passé c'est un sujet passionnant on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler je
voudrais vous rappeler une bibliographie
qui a servi à préparer cette émission
Thomas Gomart les ambitions inavoués
chez Talandier Anne lovergeon dans le
temps vous avez publié cette femme qui
résiste qui vous correspond est-ce que
vous préparez
quelque chose d'un ouvrage là oui je
prépare quelque chose pour l'an prochain
qui est une promesse que j'ai faite à
François Mitterrand je vais accomplir
alors Christian Saint-Étienne je
rappelle qu'au dernier livre était sur
le conflit sino-américain pour la
domination mondiale chez alpha enfin il
y a une double Guerre mondiale il y a
une guerre géostratégique entre la
chaîne des États-Unis mais il y a une
guerre géo économique pour la domination
du monde numérique et les et les
Américains dominent 100% des grandes
plateformes mondiales mais on parle
souvent des licornes il domine aussi 80%
des licornes mondiales en capitalisation
et ces deux pays qui font 43% du PIB
mondial à sur 60% des dépenses
militaires donc c'est vraiment ce géant
et quand on voit une Europe ouverte à
tous les vents on a des sujets
d'inquiétude merci pour ces chiffres
édifiants alors Olivier lui Enzy vous
allez publier les néo industriels aux
éditions déviations en deux mots c'est
quoi c'est néo industrie on vient de
dire et on le voit on change de
paradigme et environnemental et en
géopolitique et on voit qu'on doit
reconstruire une nouvelle industrie la
question que je me suis posée c'est
projetons-nous en 2040 et posons-nous la
question Quels auront été les acteurs
les chefs d'entreprise qu'elles auront
été leur motivation d'où ils viennent
qui nous auront permis de faire cette
renaissance industrielle merci à vous
merci à l'équipe de LCP et avant de nous
quitter je voudrais vous laisser avec
cette citation la priorité de la France
devrait être l'accélération de la
préparation au choix que nous n'allons
pas manquer de subir plutôt que la
recherche hypothétique d'une position de
surplomb c'est une position c'est une
pensée de Thomas gaumart qui est le
président de l'IFRI
[Musique]